führungsdebatte in der cdu nach dem
wahldebakel in thüringen gibt es
heftigen streit friedrich merz
attackiert die kanzlerin regierungskrise
im libanon nach massenprotesten kündigt
ministerpräsident hariri seinen
rücktritt an und cloud lösung für europa
mit dem projekt garics will europa seine
daten sicherer machen und die
abhängigkeit von amazon und co
verringern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend ihnen allen
und willkommen zu den heute -nachrichten
die vom sport hat in etwa 15 minuten
norbert lehmann dankeschön wurden von
mir
die niederlage in thüringen hat in der
cdu
den kampf um die macht neu angeheizt
nicht mehr nur parteichefin kramp
karrenbauer sondern auch die
bundeskanzlerin wird offen attackiert
am heftigsten von friedrich merz einem
der möglichen kanzlerkandidaten der cdu
märz bezeichnet im zdf die arbeit der
groko als grottenschlecht der kanzlerin
wirft er mangelnde führung und
untätigkeit vor die cdu hat in diesem
jahr massiv wähler verloren etwa bei der
europawahl oder bei den landtagswahlen
in brandenburg und sachsen und gerade
auch in thüringen hier minus 11,7
prozent punkte wie es in der partei gärt
zeigt mathis feldhoff
es ist der tag nach dem großen wahl
debakel doch wer glaubt dass angela
merkel den auftritt beim digital gipfel
nutzt um tacheles zu reden wird
enttäuscht stattdessen stehen die sätze
von friedrich merz aus dem gestrigen
zdf-interview im raum
wir sind in einer ganz schwierigen
situation das hängt nach meinem eindruck
aber vor allem damit zusammen dass sich
seit jahren über dieses land wie eine
wie ein wie ein nebel teppich die die
untätigkeit und die mangelnde führung
durch die bundeskanzlerin legt das
gesamte erscheinungsbild der regierung
sei grottenschlecht kritisiert der mann
den merkel vor jahren ausgebootet hat
vor allem ihr sei die wahlniederlage
anzulasten
märz trifft damit einen nerv in der cdu
und der ruf die merkel freunde auf den
plan
die union streitet offen über die
kanzlerin wie ich sehe auch niemanden in
einer partei der das für besonders klug
hält wenn jetzt von solchen menschen
ratschläge kommen
die sag mal im leben nicht das erreicht
haben was sie erreichen wollten und
jetzt die chance nutzen das nochmal
auszutragen und das halte ich einfach
für ganz ganz schlechten stil schon
länger vermissten unionsabgeordnete dass
merkel sich öffentlich einmischt beim
streit um eine schutzzone in syrien etwa
beim maut debakel und minister scheuer
oder bei sie
was kehrtwende bei der seenotrettung
merkel schweigt es sind wenige
unionsspitzen die sich heute
positionieren die union ist fraglos in
der schwierigen lage
ich teile die kritik von friedrich merz
nicht
und noch ein minister reagiert auch jens
spahn fordert ein ende der
personaldebatte klingt dann aber doch
wie merz wir haben zu viele themen die
seit zehn seit 20 jahren immer wieder
diskutiert werden wurden aber nicht
wirklich einen unterschied gemacht wird
was entschieden wird
die thüringen wahl legt eine
führungsdebatte in der cdu offen eine
debatte die die union entzweit unterleib
energy in berlin worum geht es hier um
alte rechnungen oder um den sturz der
kanzlerin also für friedrich merz sind
das wahrscheinlich zwei seiten derselben
medaille ist wer für ihn sicherlich eine
genugtuung wenn seine kritik dazu
beitragen würde seine alte erzrivalin
angela merkel aus dem amt zu treiben
er selber rechnet sich immer noch
chancen aus auf eine mögliche
kanzlerkandidatur das ist hier in berlin
ein offenes geheimnis dieses
eigeninteresse muss man immer im
hinterkopf behalten wenn man seine
kritik hört aber er greift diese kritik
eben auch nicht völlig aus der luft
sondern ergreift damit eine stimmung auf
die es in der cdu gibt vor allem bei den
gruppierungen die die cdu schon seit
amtsantritt der kanzlerin auf dem
falschen kurs gesehen und dieser diesen
stimmen gibt er jetzt noch einmal eine
sehr laute stimme am ende vielleicht
dann eben auch mit dem ziel die
kanzlerin aus dem amt zu treiben kann er
damit erfolg haben
er hat zumindest keinen schlechten
zeitpunkt dafür gewählt denn die wahlen
sind jetzt vorbei das entsetzen ist groß
die disziplin und der zusammenhalt in
die partei versucht hat zu zeigen haben
sich nicht in gute guten wahlergebnissen
niedergeschlagen und jetzt gibt es wenig
was die kritiker noch zurückhält
auffallend ist dass es nicht besonders
viele stimmen gegeben hat die sich heute
vor angela merkel gestellt haben dass
die stimmen der kritiker deutlich lauter
sind als die der verteidiger das
entscheidende wird jetzt sicherlich sein
in welche richtung diese
unterschiedlichen stimmungen kippen bis
zum parteitag im november auf dem es
dann zum showdown kommen kann
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
berlin giacometti war das für den
schmerz und das erscheinungsbild der
großen koalition fast fünf minuten
dauert das zdf interview dazu auf heute
de können sie sich ansehen und anhören
ein streitpunkt in der cdu ist wie man
auf die schwierige regierungsbildung in
thüringen reagiert mike mohring cdu
spitzenkandidat dort hat er gestern eine
zusammenarbeit mit der linken von
ministerpräsident ramelow ins gespräch
gebracht heute ruderte er zurück eine
koalition mit der linken schließt er aus
ebenso eine duldung einer neuen rot rot
grünen regierung persönlich reden mit
dem ministerpräsidenten wird er aber
schon
wir schauen auf das pulverfass syrien
und die türkische offensive im norden
des landes jetzt berichten aktivisten
dass es kämpfe zwischen mit der türkei
verbündeten milizen und den truppen von
syriens machthaber assad gegeben habe
außerdem ist am nachmittag die
sechstägige waffenruhe zwischen der
türkei und kurdische kurdischen gpg
milizen in nordsyrien zu ende gegangen
während dieser zeit sollten sich die
kunden aus der sogenannten
sicherheitszone zurückziehen
brase ist für uns an der türkisch
syrischen grenze york wie ist die
situation jetzt nachdem die waffenruhe
ausgelaufen ist also wir befinden uns
hier direkt gegenüber der syrischen
grenzstadt kassaline und wir konnten von
hier aus sehen dass es auf der anderen
seite artilleriefeuer gegeben hat man
hört auch vereinzelt
maschinengewehrfeuer das sollen aber nur
einzelne scharmützel sein
das russische verteidigungsministerium
hatte bereits vor ablauf der frist
verkündet dass sich die syrisch
kurdischen miliz vereinbarungsgemäß aus
der pufferzone zurückgezogen habe
damit wollte man wohl druck ausüben auf
die türkische regierung damit hier auch
wenn sich noch einzelne gpg kräfte in
der zone aufhalten auf größere militär
operationen verzichtet der türkische
regierungssprecher meldete sich dann
auch kurz darauf und kündete an dass man
ab morgen gemeinsame patrouillen
durchführen wolle im grenzstreifen
zusammen mit russischen truppen um sich
zu überzeugen dass die epg sich
tatsächlich zurückgezogen hat das heißt
es sieht so aus dass die türkei
tatsächlich erst einmal auf weitere
militäroperationen verzicht vielen dank
für diese informationen aus der türkei
japan das nachbarland von syrien der
libanon steckt seit langem in einer
tiefen wirtschaftskrise seit zwei wochen
protestieren dort zehntausende menschen
unter anderem gegen korruption und die
jahrzehntelange misswirtschaft der
regierung nun zog ministerpräsident
hariri die reißleine und kündigte seinen
rücktritt an
aus dem libanon berichtet axel stein wir
sind ein volk im libanon ist dass der
ruf der stunde
der rücktritt von premier hariri am tag
13 der proteste sorgt er für kollektive
glücksgefühle
wir haben wir es erhofft der druck von
der straße war zu groß für uns libanesen
ist das fantastisch seit 13 tagen und
nächten stehen singen tanzen sie auf dem
märtyrer-platz in beirut fordern den
systemwechsel
denn der libanon steckt seit jahren tief
in der krise einen rekord schuldenberg
hohe arbeitslosigkeit und korruption
während die aus religiösen gruppen
zusammengesetzte regierung immer reicher
wird
heute sage ich ihnen ehrlich ich stecke
in einer sackgasse
wir müssen uns der krise stellen ich
werde dem staatspräsidenten michelle
augen meinen rücktritt anbieten
bei ihm und allen libanesen
kurz zuvor ein prügelnder mob zieht
durch beruht geht auf unbewaffnete
demonstranten los anhänger der
schiitischen gruppen hisbollah und amal
sie hatten die proteste von beginn an
scharf kritisiert es war eine
machtdemonstration eine blitzaktion
sicherlich kein spontaner ausbruch von
gewalt
die schiitischen kräfte im land wollten
zeigen wer am ende des tages das sagen
hat und dann ging alles ganz schnell
während der premier noch seinen
rücktritt einreicht feiern sie schon
wieder vor seinem amtssitz fragen sich
allerdings auch ob die nacht nicht neue
gewalt bringen wird seit fast sechs
jahren herrscht krieg in der ost ukraine
pro-russische kämpfer wollen die
abspaltung eines gebietes im osten
erzingen jetzt vielleicht ein schritt
hin zu einer friedlichen lösung
bislang stehen sich regierungstruppen
und milizen an dieser front linie
gegenüber heute haben sich die truppen
bei dem ort solo t auf beiden seiten
etwas zurückgezogen dies galt als eine
voraussetzung für neue diplomatische
verhandlungen
großer schreck heute morgen beim digital
gipfel in dortmund beim verlassen der
bühne stolperte wirtschaftsminister
altmaier und stürzte die veranstaltung
wurde unterbrochen der 61 jährige ins
krankenhaus gebracht er twitterte aber
schon wieder außer prellungen und
platzwunden offenbar nichts ernstes
eigentlich wollte peter altmaier in
dortmund über den umgang mit einem der
wichtigsten rohstoffe unserer zeit
sprechen daten
denn immer mehr europäische unternehmen
speichern ihre daten in sogenannten
virtuellen wolken sprich einem netzwerk
aus fremden servern
dort werden speicherplatz und
rechenleistung bereitgestellt doch
amerikanische internet riesen wie amazon
microsoft oder google dominieren den
markt europas antwort eine eigene cloud
namens gaia ex dominik müller
so könnte der warentransport der zukunft
aussehen sich selbst steuernde mini
transporter die genau wissen was von wo
nach wo gebracht werden muss und die
sich dabei nicht in die quere kommen
möglich macht das künstliche intelligenz
das heißt die blitzschnelle speicherung
und verarbeitung großer daten schätze
auf servern die in der regel allerdings
in den usa stehen was eine information
die will man nicht betreten teilen man
möchte die souveränität über diese daten
behalten und das ist bei amerikanischen
klotz im mal nun nicht gegeben nach
cloud kann in der stadt hinein schauen
und wir müssen dann letztendlich nicht
mehr was mit diesen worten gemacht wird
da ja es nennt sich die antwort der
bundesregierung auf dieses problem die
speicherung riesiger datenmengen soll
künftig auf europäischen servern
erfolgen nach europäischen
datenschutzstandards ein thema das nicht
nur die digitalbranche sondern
mittlerweile die wirtschaft insgesamt um
tricks kennt natürlich früher kommen
können aber grundsätzlich ist es so dass
wir jetzt starten müssen das thema
digital anzupacken und die souveränität
auch bei uns in europa zu halten
von daher unterstützen wir als industrie
gaia ixia ein appell nun gas zu geben
kanzlerin merkel verspricht das zu tun
und appelliert ihrerseits an die
wirtschaft mitzumachen bei dem projekt
und zu erkennen welchen wert daten und
ihre verknüpfung mittlerweile haben
sozusagen aus der hand nehmen lassen
dann wird das für den industriestandort
deutschland ein böses erwachen geben
in einem jahr soll die europäische daten
klaut konkretere formen annehmen um
riesiges know-how besser schützen zu
können
nach china das land duldet keinen
widerstand die behörden in hongkong
haben den jungen aktivisten josua wang
von den kommunalwahlen im november
ausgeschlossen
der 23-jährige ist eines der
bekanntesten gesichter der pro
demokratischen corvette protestbewegung
dort und auch chinesische journalisten
werden noch mehr als bisher überprüft
seit gestern lässt präsident mit einer
app ihre loyalität testen aus peking
berichtet ulf röller pressekonferenzen
in china sind gut inszenierte show
veranstaltungen
fragen und antworten fein abgestimmt die
gleichschaltung erlebt nun einen neuen
höhepunkt auf einer sogenannten cap
müssen die journalisten die gedankenwelt
des chinesischen präsidenten studieren
und dann einen realitätstest bestehen
wer durchfällt verliert seinen job ich
lerne jeden tag mit der keb nicht nur
jetzt wegen der prüfung aber die sorgt
dafür dass ich die app noch öfter
benutzt 100 fragen mindestens 80 muss
man wissen um zu bestehen
kostprobe was verlangt präsident ski von
politischen kadern wissen oder loyalität
zur partei
loyalität ist richtig er will sein
gesicht nicht zeigen denn wer als
journalist die machthaber kritisiert
lebt gefährlich
die journalisten können nicht unabhängig
arbeiten sie sind teilt der regierung
haben der partei zu dienen können nicht
selbst entscheiden was er denkt was er
sagt ist gesetz in china präsident
schuldet keinen widerstand 150
journalisten sitzen derzeit im gefängnis
ich vermisse wie es früher war damals
hat die journalistin mehr freiheiten es
gab kritische berichte die mädchen haben
nur noch eine propaganda rolle nach
presse denn sie ist der gesinnungstest
keine zensur
die gleichschaltung der journalisten
nennt er loyalität ungläubiges
kopfschütteln löst jedes jahr das
schwarzbuch des bundes der steuerzahler
aus es listet rund 100 beispiele auf wie
steuergelder vom staat sinnlos
verschwendet werden so zum beispiel die
gescheiterte pkw maut von
bundesverkehrsminister scheuer oder die
umbenennung der bundesstraße 6 in
sachsen anhalt zur autobahn
die neuen verkehrsschilder kosteten 3
millionen euro noch ein blick nach
kalifornien dort fressen sich die
verheerenden waldbrände immer weiter
seit tagen riskieren tausende helfer ihr
leben und versuchen die flammen
einzudämmen mehr als 180.000 menschen
wurden aufgefordert ihre häuser zu
verlassen
hitze trockenheit
und winde fachten die feuer immer wieder
an eine der meistbefahrenen autobahnen
direkt an los angeles musste zeitweise
gesperrt werden
wahnsinnsbilder wir sind beim fußball
norbert dfb pokal heute und morgen 2002
rund und da steht das duell bewusster
gegen borussia im mittelpunkt vor zehn
tagen hatte ja der bvb die gladbacher in
der liga knapp geschlagen morgen abend
nun die neuauflage im pokal bei der es
vor allem für dortmunds trainer favre um
viel geht
kaum zu glauben dass diese dortmunder
jubel bilder über den 1 0 siegtreffer
für marco reus gegen mönchengladbach
erst zehn tage alt sind und dass der
hier noch strahlende lucien favre nach
blutleeren auftritten in mailand und auf
schalke längst um seinen trainer job
bangen muss kritisch beäugt von bvb
geschäftsführer watzke
jetzt bringt nicht darüber zu sprechen
nicht machen mein weg weiter und ich war
mein best den gerüchten um eine
bevorstehende entlassung versuchte
bvb-sportdirektor zorc heute die schärfe
zu nehmen noch keine gedanken drüber
gemacht wann wer wo wie entlassen wird
ich glaube sind der liga noch nicht viel
passiert aber wenn gladbach morgen etwas
mehr glück haben sollte als vor zehn
tagen
könnte der ton durch ausdauer werten in
dortmund jan lennard struff hat das
achtelfinale des atp masters turnier in
paris erreicht der 29 jährige bezwang
den vorjahressieger kern katchalov aus
russland in einem hochklassigen match in
drei sätzen
von beginn an ist das selbstvertrauen
von stoff spürbar tie break im ersten
satz ein pfeilschneller aufschlag von
204 kilometern pro stunde bringt die
satzführung doch katja auf die aktuelle
nummer neun der welt schlägt zurück ein
break reichten zum 6 3 im zweiten satz
stroh vergibt den dritten satz seine
führung und alles läuft auf einen
erneuten tie-break hinaus doch der mann
aus warstein erhält sich die chancen 7
zu 5 durch einen mutigen netzangriff
einen offensiv schlag und einen
platzierten schmetterball später ist die
überraschung perfekt
die aktuelle nummer 49 der welt jan
lennard struff steht im achtelfinale von
paris das was von mir noch was
erfreuliches zum schluss morgen wird
fast überall sonnig am späten nachmittag
regnet auch an den alpen nicht mehr die
details hat gleich gunter czisch wir
empfehlen das heute schon mal um viertel
vor zehn darin spricht marietta slomka
mit dem schleswig holsteinischen
ministerpräsidenten daniel günther von
der cdu
das war es von uns machen sie sich noch
einen schönen abend danke für ihr
interesse und bis morgen wenn sie morgen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
glaube liebe zuschauer frost im norden
und im süden immer noch der regen die
unterschiede bleiben recht groß morgen
noch mal in deutschland vor allen dingen
auch heute nacht der luftdruck steigt ja
wir haben klaren himmel morgen in
deutschland das heißt auch viel
sonnenschein aber hier über den alpen
ziehen immer noch die regengebiete
teilweise schnellste auch und wann es
damit schluss wahrscheinlich morgen am
späten nachmittag heute nacht regnet es
aber noch an den alpen vor allen dingen
in der zweiten nachthälfte auch etwas
stärker sonst bilden sich teilweise in
der mitte nebelfelder aus und im norden
wird es richtig frostig die luft ist
trocken sternenklarer himmel
morgen früh 0 bis -5 grad hier unter den
regenwolken bleibt es deutlich milder
und tagsüber die temperaturen ändern
sich eigentlich kaum im regen 5 grad an
den alpen sonst meist acht bis elf grad
es wird allerdings ein sehr sonniger tag
in norddeutschland vor allen dingen an
den küsten dann haben wir uns vom harz
bis zum erzgebirge nebel und hochnebel
das dauert bis der sich aufgelöst hat
und nach süden hin wechseln auch sonne
und wolken etwa bis zur donau das ist
wieder stark bewölkt an den alpen regnet
es noch aber am späten nachmittag lässt
der regen dort auch nach und wir haben
einen schwachen ostwind der donnerstag
wird meist trocken auch in
süddeutschland aber ab freitag und
samstag wird es zwar milder aber auch
nasa ich wünsche dir noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut